good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
3998 Containment class safe disruption
class vam and risk class warning
special containment procedures SCP 3998
is to be contained in Secure holding
Locker
3981 or shl 3998 1 shl 3998 1 is to be
fireproofed and vacuum sealed to prevent
access to oxygen SCP 3998 and shl 3998 1
are scheduled for cleaning every day at
9:00 a.m. if any d-class Personnel
spontaneously ignite the seal to SCP
3998 Containment loger must be inspected
and repaired or replaced as necessary
for safety reasons site 34 must hold
d-class Personnel particularly those who
have been convicted of first-degree
murder charges and domestic abuse if
staff are found to have been targeted by
SCP 3998 they are to be investigated and
then
processed description SCP 3998 is a
human cadaver which expired late 17th
century SCP 3998 lacks any legs and is
covered in extensive fourth degree burns
sometime after its death SCP 3998
remains were collected and fashioned
into a scarecrow held together by wicker
nails and wire along with its severe
burns SCP 3998 appears to have suffered
blunt force trauma to multiple regions
of its body it is unclear if SCP 3998
died as a result from one of the two or
both see examination
3998 6 the object constantly exudes A
flammable liquid from its bones which is
composed primarily of ethanol and human
fat each night between 11:00 p.m. and
4:00 a.m. SCP 3998 ignites and is
engulfed in flames however despite being
highly flammable SCP 3998 does not
suffer any structural damage when SCP
3998 is on fire
and when not contained properly the
nearest person who meets certain
criteria will also spontaneously ignite
SCP 3998 targets those who have killed
or physically abused a romantic partner
if SCP 3998 is unable to ignite itself
SCP 3998 cannot ignite targets instead
those who would have been targeted only
develop brief mild pains to either their
chest or to the back of their head as
targets are left burning large
quantities of boiling ethanol will
appear in their stomach this large
influx of alcohol typically induces
vomiting which causes further external
Burns and will often cause permanent
nerve and organ damage if they survive
the initial burning eventually their
body fat particularly in the Torso or
stomach region will begin to melt this
process is extremely rapid often causing
Massive Internal damage if the target is
successful F extinguished before they
die if fourth degree burns if left to
burn the combination of melted fat and
ethanol will cause the stomach to
violently rupture often bisecting the
victim in the process those that SCP
3998 effects cannot be extinguished
until SCP 3999 itself is also
extinguished addendum 3998 1 forward
3998 0 SCP 3998
documents the following is a partial set
of documents and materials related to
SCP
3998 as well as related correspondences
and articles discovered on the property
where SCP 3998 was originally found
these documents may only be viewed by
staff with specialized 3998 clearance
the current site 34 administrator and
those with o5
designations Journal 3998 1 for
the following are excerpts found in
contemporaneous journals from Salem that
appear relevant to SCP
3998 documentary evidence suggests a
connection between SCP 3998 and one
Candice Hayes a 17th century resident of
Salem most were found in basements and
attics of historic buildings located
near the property SCP 3998 was found
Journal 1 author Mary 168 82 we attended
the wedding of Aiden Hayes and Candace
Candace seemed rather distraught the
lady's father went through all that
trouble to see her married it would be a
shame if she did not appreciate it
especially with a sir as respected as
Aiden Hayes Journal 2 author Mary
1683 Candice has been different she used
to keep her hair tied but now she's been
keeping it long I see bruises on her
often
she's been looking for every excuse to
be alone just so she can wend to the
forest Journal 3 author Mary
1683 something piqued my interest today
Margaret pointed out how Candice sh from
her chores lately and I heard that she
might be a bad wife making Aiden angry
bruises make sense now Journal 4 author
Mary
1691 I was washing the laundry and I
heard Candace shouting at her husband I
went out to ask her what was wrong but
she snapped at me calling me nosy the
amount of disrespect and Scorn in the
mistress was remarkable though to be
expected I have half a mind to complain
Journal 5 author Mary
1692 I've been hearing some troubling
things about Candice lately ever since
she wed Aiden she's been wanding off
more plus I've heard rumors that her
interests are not with men the devil
must have a hold on her maybe Aiden will
know what to do I'll just have to tell
him
tomorrow interview
forward the following interview is taken
on June 8th 1693 by judge William
stouton and the constables of Salem
interview has been edited from its
original document for
clarity when presented with a warrant
for your arrest you fled immediately
it's this your refusal to speak only
until you've been branded and your
husband's testimony that places you
under
suspicion what do you have to say in
your
defense I have no words for it I shalt
not lie the accusations are true so you
admit being a witch and you admit to
consorting with an evil spirit I do
although she is not evil in heart what
in the name of God would lead thee down
such a path to perform such detestable
Arts they are not detestable they would
work for anyone be they God or Satan or
anyone and no one they are merely a form
of tool you haven't answered the
question isn't it obvious I did not ask
to marry yet I was waved to a bastard in
my father's church he does not respect
me to him I am his property just as
Lilith has done that is the Woman's
Place you only had to be a faithful wife
quiet how could I be faithful to a man I
detest I care only for clish and I'll be
damned if I am with anyone but her it
would be my Dy wish to see that bastard
on his knees and treated as I have
Clovis is that the name of the devil
that you conjured it Bewitched you she
Bewitched me but not in the manner you
think it doesn't matter we have your
confession an exception will be made for
a witch as Brazen as you instead of a
typical hanging you shall be burned at
the stake we will see how your Clovis
treats you in hell in the name of our
Sovereign Lord and Lady the king and
queen may God have mercy on your
soul so be
it document 3998
3 to the people of of this Hamlet an
execution of a witch on the 10th day of
June
1693 Aiden Hayes has caught his wife
Candice consorting with the devil and
one of his evil angels the evil witch
has been justly convicted and shall be
put to death by burning if you are able
come to the center of town we need good
men willing to stand between Satan's
Hall and our women and children Hayes
and honest God-fearing man and the
victim of this witch has requested to be
the one to start the flame
himself letter
39984 dear Candace if you are reading
this something has gone wrong you must
be angry confused maybe depressed you
have given your soul to me when you were
young and we've been together since
but now that you've died this means your
soul is supposed to be mine now but I
don't want it I want you I'm sorry we
were caught I'm sorry for what was done
to you over the years I'm still here for
you even if I'm not here with
you so I've brought you back they put
you to the P but I only needed the bones
to make you yourself again I had to
remove your flesh and I couldn't save
your legs they were too far gone I may
do with what was around me I reaped from
the field and wrapped your bones in WKA
you'll have to find a
replacement speaking of your husband
restocked the Shelf with gin and while
you are
flammable fire will only make you
stronger this time you won't be heard
from it ever again you have the power to
make him feel worse than what you felt
just a thought make him wish he could go
to
hell I love you and
farewell
CL note this letter was found in the
cellar of the estate under a pillow the
letter was still sealed and remained
unopened document
3998 5
forward the following document is an
excerpt from an urban legend website
regarding an entity called The Wicker
witch given supporting evidence this is
hypothesized to be Candace
Hayes the Wicker
witch there once was a woman who was wed
to a man against her will she hated the
man but obeyed her father's wishes for
her to Bear children for his church an
evil spirit saw this and came to her
while she was out gathering in the woods
the succubus took her hand and told her
I can help you live the life you truly
wish to live you only need to toss this
one aside in exchange will you take my
soul the woman asked yes said the she
devil will I be rich the woman asked you
shall provide the power that money could
not hope to provide the spirit told her
will I have a real love the woman asked
the spirit paused I do not know the
woman pondered the offer and asked one
more time what shall you do with My Soul
this surprised the devil but it kept its
composure it told her it will be
consumed nothing more nothing less the
woman accepted and met with the spirit
every day for 10 years and grew close
she brought the spirit berries and
trinkets and it brought her advice and
its companionship it answered her
questions and taught her its Magics the
woman became a witch and she used her
power to torment her husband the same
way he tormented her one day her husband
husband followed her and found her
shaking the Devil's Tail he quietly went
back to the town and gathered up a mob
they tied her up to a steak broke her
legs and hung her up like a scarecrow to
burn they dumped her body down the
mountain but the devil found her to give
her back her soul it wrapped her bones
in reads and used the fire of her soul
to keep her alive but the fire consumed
her and she wanted her old husband to
burn with her in the middle of the night
she dowsed herself in her old husband's
gin and set herself Ablaze once again
she dragged her husband out of bed and
fell upon him she burned his face and
with her thumb dug his eyes out of his
skull she burned with him till his flesh
melted to the floor and the smell could
be found all across Salem she grabbed
his legs and pulled and pulled till they
came loose so that she could use them to
walk again only one of them walked out
of that burning house and it was her
his body was never found and some say
that the husband feudly crawled out of
the wreckage looking for his missing
legs others say that the witch took his
body elsewhere so that she could
continue to torture him but many more
say that he's in a hell of the witch's
own creation burning over and over again
and bringing those like him down with
him punishing them forever as for the
witch herself only one thing can be said
for sure the the Wicker witch
lives examination
6 forward further examination of SCP
3998 revealed inconsistencies in bone
structure or position suggesting that
the gavver is not Candace Hayes as
originally thought below is a medical
report of the
findings report of Investigation by site
34 Salem Massachusetts decedent unknown
SCP
3998 race white sex male age 32 her
address
redacted
mwsd occupation
unknown type of death violent found dead
suspicious unusual or
unnatural investigation agency SCP
Foundation site 34
Department K description of clothing
unclothed eyes unknown hair black
mustache Black Beard black weight 5 kg
length 0.9 M body temperature 30° C date
and time
redacted marks and wounds SCP 3998 has
sustained severe damage to its ribs and
skull implying it was hit several times
with a blunt object fourth deegree Burns
can be found along its torso arms and
skull damage around the eye socket legs
appear to have been amputated postmortem
and are missing probable cause of death
fourth degree burns or trauma to the
skull manner of death
homicide at endom 3998
2 after SCP 3998 was contained there was
a noted increase in the number of
murders per day in Massachusetts
increasing from 0.32 to
0.48 a large portion of these deaths are
arson homicides and the victims are
known perpetrators of violent crimes
victims appear covered in extensive
fourth degree burns and are gutted from
chest to
pelvis information on these murders
could not be contained due to the
corpses being discovered in public
displays and being attributed to the
Wicker w witch the public has been led
to believe that the perpetrator of these
killings is a serial killer using the
Wicker witch Legend as an inspiration
that the Wicker Witch is fictional and
that no witch burnings happened in Salem
classification to uid pending on the
capture and containment of the person
responsible this concludes today's
lecture thank you for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
bigp O crop guy James Saba Irish
wristwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent zazan
worthy fire cubster Dean
Dingus that loser bred peit Ruan
O'Brien
grimnir extra moments 123 Swift raw U
malus Big Booty Judy Desmond K and
oscuro
vision if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
[Music]
you